when you get together with your friends
our doctors I'm guessing you have a lot
of friends who are still doc yes that's
all do you talk medicine with them or do
you sort of are you mr. showbiz guy when
you talk to them no we actually just
talked it's the same thing like what we
have at one of my best friends is also
another medical consultant on the show
and we find ourselves like whoa tell me
the office gossip it's still like more
like medical stuff even at my at my
bachelor party when I got married like
13 years ago it was all my best friends
who were all doctors this is way before
the hangover way before mr. chow it was
way before that we were four doctors or
five five doctors went to like Spearmint
Rhino in Las Vegas and we couldn't be
more pathetic nerds like not knowing it
like not really not going into strip
clubs and one of my buddies I'm not
making this up he he would yeah he ended
up diagnosing a stripper of her ailment
what yeah and I'm strippers like about
to give him a lap dance
instead nothing hurts talking to her
about her ailment yeah and I I do
remember hearing well miracle and
irritable bowel you get constipation and
diarrhea so and then after that
subsequently there like five strippers
in line waiting for him to
[Applause]
I was thinking maybe it was something
dermatological yeah how they got to
diarrhea I would be really interested to
see out one day how they got the bad guy
I don't know all roads eventually lead
to dire it and with that this bedtime
stories
you